Welcome everybody to
another episode of Functional
Programming 101
and today we are going to talk about
declaring types and classes ourselves.
Up to now
only in the lecture on parsers
we have defined types ourselves
but for the rest we have assumed that
the types are there. For example we have
assumed
that the type list exists and we have
assumed that tuples exist
but of course, just like we can define
new functions in Haskell
we also want to define new types.
What we are going to do in
this lecture is we are going to show
how to declare new types and how to
declare new type classes
but also I'm going to compare and
contrast this
with typical object-oriented programming
how these things work there. And what
you will see
is that although the syntax is a little
bit different a lot of the ideas are
very common.
And this is a general thing that I like
to do. Instead of emphasizing the
differences
I think it is often much more productive
to emphasize
commonalities.
Maybe you should try this too.
As programmers we often go: well,
but, no...
It is much more productive to say:
Yes, and...
and emphasize
what is common. And so I'm going to
try to do that here
and please take that as a metalesson
for this lecture.
In Haskell we can
define an alias for an existing type
by saying type String
equals another type or
type new name equals another type.
And in this case we are defining String
as an alias for a list of characters.
And this is an idea
that we have used throughout all the
lectures. Every time we saw
a String
we treated it as a list of characters,
but in types we often wrote String
because
that's what we wanted to convey. But
when we are coding against strings
we want to see them as a list of
characters.
And here this type declaration achieves
that.
This is just another name for this type.
What we often do is, just like with
String,
we use type aliases to convey the
meaning
or our intent of what we want to do. For
example: instead of having a pair of
integers
we can say: we declare this as
type position. And then instead of
writing (Int,Int) everywhere
we can write Pos. So the origin, that's
at coordinates (0,0). And then we want to
move a position to the left. So this is a
function that takes a position
and returns a new position. And it
takes a pair
(x,y) and it subtracts 1 from x.
And now by looking at this type
you get a better idea of what it is doing.
And the fact that we are using pairs to
represent positions
is really just an implementation detail.
Another example here
is a parametrized type
alias. So here we define the type of
pairs
of type a
as pairs of type a.
So the type of pairs
of values of type a, are pairs of values
of type a. And now we can define functions
over that type. For example we can take a
pair of integers
and return an integer by multiplying the
two.
Or we can take a single value
and copy that into a pair
and there's the function copy, which
takes an x
and returns a tuple that contains
another copy of x.
Type declarations
of course can be nested.
If we define position as a pair of
integers
then we can define another type synonym
to mean position to position.
A transformation of a position is a
function that takes one position
and returns another position. So
in this case here
we could have defined this function here
to have type
Trans. One important thing here is that
these
type synonyms are really just synonyms.
They are just abbreviations
which means that they cannot be
recursive. So in this case
when you define type Tree to be
a pair of an Int and a list of Trees
this is not allowed.
You can define, and we will see that
later, it is
no problem to define recursive types in
Haskell
but they always have to go via a nominal
type.
And this is a restriction that
many languages have. If you have an
object-oriented
language, typically it has a
nominal type system and that makes it
easier to check
whether two types are equal or one type
is a subtype of another.
If you have purely structural types
that becomes
a little bit more difficult. So that is
typically the reason for that. But if
you are interested in
programming languages and type systems, the
field of structural versus nominal types
is a very interesting
field and you can spend years researching
that and reading papers on
it and
get a PhD in that area. What I
said is when we want to
make a recursive type, we have to go
through a nominal type.
And the way we define nominal types in
Haskell
is via data declarations.
Here we are defining a new type named
Bool
and it has two constructors
True and False.
And since these constructors don't
take arguments
they are at the same time values. If you
know Scala, you will see that Scala
case classes are very similar to algebraic
data types. But
even if you don't know Scala,
but say you know Java or C#
one way to look at these data
declarations is as follows:
this is an abstract base class Bool and
then
the types here on the right hand side
are the subtypes, so False extends Bool
and True extends Bool. And since Bool
itself is abstract, you cannot create an
instance of Bool
you can only create instances of False
and True
but both have type Bool. And in Haskell
True and False don't have their own
types, they always have type Bool
so that is even simpler than having an
abstract base class
and two derived types. As I mentioned
the values on the right hand side
there, True and False
are typically called constructors.
With the explanation I gave
with the abstract type and the
subtypes, that makes sense. They correspond
to constructors in an object-oriented
language.
In Haskell type and constructor names
must begin with an uppercase letter.
Functions and type variables begin with
a lowercase letter
and types and constructor names must
begin
with an uppercase letter. And these
algebraic
data types, another way to look at them
are as context-free grammars
where the thing on the left hand side is
non-terminal
and then the right hand side can contain
terminals, which are the constructors
that themselves can recursively
contain other types, like a grammar
can contain
recursively on the right hand side
non-terminals as well.
Here is an example of
a slightly more interesting algebraic
data type.
It is like a boolean thing with
three values, three valued booleans, so
we have Yes
No and don't know. This is maybe
like SQL
where this is like NULL. So it is
three valued
logic. And now we can use this thing
to say I want to have a list of answers:
[Yes, No, Unknown].
And now I'm going to define another
function that flips the answers.
This is like the generalization of
negation.
If I have Yes and I flip it,
it becomes No.
If I have No and I flip it,
it becomes Yes.
And if I don't know and I flip it
I still don't know. If you are
familiar with SQL
this will be very similar, where
unknown plays the role of NULL.
Here is the standard OO example of
circles and rectangles and shapes.
In Haskell it looks as follows:
we have an
abstract base class Shape and two
subtypes: Circle
and Rectangle. Both of them are Shapes
and in Haskell Circle and Rectangle
don't have their own types.
So when you create a circle using the
Circle constructor
you get a Shape and if you create a
rectangle using the Rectangle
constructor
you also get a Shape. That is the
main difference between
algebraic data types in Haskell and
the way you typically write
inheritance hierarchies
in an OO language. Now we can
use this constructor to create
a particular Shape, a square. So
we take a value for
the first coordinate there and we create
a Shape
by just duplicating that value here. And
we can
compute the area of a Shape
and that will return a Float. Here
you see that area
is defined on Shape. And then we do
a pattern match here, which is very much
like doing
a dynamic dispatch. So if
the Shape happens to be a Circle, then
I take pi * r^2.
If the Shape is a Rectangle
I just multiply the sides.
So pattern matching kind of corresponds
to virtual dispatch, when you think
of algebraic data types as object
hierarchies.
When we look at these constructors
that we define in here
they implicitly define constructors,
functions that take a Float and
return a Shape
and
a second function that takes two Floats
and returns a Shape. And these functions
are called Circle
and Rectangle. So if you look at the type,
if you ask
:t Circle, Haskell will tell you
Float -> Shape and if you ask
what is the type of Rectangle, it will
tell you it is a function that takes two
Floats
and returns a Shape.
So again, the analogy with objects
is still intact. You define
your subtypes and really what you get
for free
is constructors to construct these types.
We mentioned the
Maybe type a couple of times. The Maybe
type is like a list
that is either empty or has a single
value.
Usually it's convenient to just use
list, but
if you really want to use the Maybe type,
maybe
you are an F# person or an ML
person where Maybe is used a lot
you just define a new algebraic
data type:
Maybe of a is either Nothing or Just
an a. And now we can define
a lot of functions, that people are
proud of
because we can take a list and we can
take the head
but if the list is empty, we return
Nothing
and if the list is not empty, we take the
head
and we return Just. I am not a big fan
of this kind of definition of head,
because we are now still stuck with this
Maybe.
So you really have now reduced a list
to a singleton list, but you have not
really gotten the head out. And in order
to go from a Maybe of a
to a, you will still run in the same
difficulties
as you had when you went from
an empty list
to a with proper head.
So that's why I typically don't
care about
this Maybe type. It stands in
the way.
It doesn't help you, because at
some point you have to get rid of it
anyway.
Alright. That was the end of part 1.
Let's take a short break and I'll see
you soon
for part 2.